an unusual common Wardak province
south-west of the Afghan capital what's
called a reduction in violence agreement
between US forces and the Taliban is
underway for the next week providing a
brief pause from attacks by both sides
the Taliban gave al Jazeera permission
to visit Wardak I mean our Emir Hobart
Allah ordered us not to clash with
anyone in any of the areas that we
control we completely obey Him according
to the full meaning of this word the
sound of sirens and bullets is common in
the capital Kabul but so far it's been
quiet some minor clashes have been
reported in parts of the country but
neither side has publicly said what
would constitute a violation of the
agreement I hope the one-week truce will
be extended until we reach a final peace
in Afghanistan
we feel very happy and we hope this
ceasefire will be real and final but
it's not actually a ceasefire the
agreement is a test of trust for both
sides as a step towards ending the 19
year long war America's longest peace
talks have been held over the past year
in Qatar's capital Doha if this
agreement is seen to be a success a
peace deal is expected to be signed on
the 29th of February
a new UN report has highlighted the
human cost of the war it says just over
3400 civilians were killed last year
with the Taliban and other
anti-government forces responsible for
about half of the deaths Afghan
government forces and their US allies
were responsible for 43 percent
thirty-five thousand five hundred
Afghans have been killed in the past
decade the total is 100 thousand when
the injured are included of course the
peace will not come in overnight there's
time needed for that negotiations all
those things but as far as the reduction
of violence's
sir there is a lot of uncertainties
Afghan government forces say they'll
continue operations against ISIL and
al-qaida which are not part of the
current agreement the next few days will
show whether a more permanent peace is
possible
Nicola gage al-jazeera